nietzsche sees that human beings are at
something of a crisis point it can
result in what nietzsche called
an over man
in which new meanings are created
or what nietzsche called the last man in
which our humanity is lost
[Music]
what nietzsche ultimately says is that
reason
does not exist
we don't know reality we create reality
to create values as nietzsche puts it in
beyond good and evil
in fact nietzsche tells us in beyond
good and evil that the ultimate
philosophical activity is the creation
of
values
nietzsche tells us that all morality is
a tyranny against nature
in the same way
poetry is a tyranny against
language
that is the poet takes language and
tries to put it into a controlled form
of say a sonnet in which you have a set
number of syllables and lines it imposes
onto language a structure that then
unleashes a kind of beauty and power
nietzsche sees morality that way also
nietzsche is in fact deeply concerned
that one set of value judgments is going
to predominate and ultimately be
victorious in our culture and another
kind will be lost nietzsche refers to
these two systems of value judgments as
forms of morality he calls them master
morality and slave morality
and each of those forms of morality have
a structure of value judgments and
nietzsche writes
as though one of those is truly superior
to the other
for nietzsche the master morality
is predicated upon
noble
value-creating
kinds of human beings life affirming and
value
creating
against
the master morality
nature gives us the slave morality
what he sometimes calls a herd
morality
here's one of his descriptions
slave morality is essentially
a morality of utility
here is the place for the origin of that
famous opposition of good and evil
and to evil
one's feelings project power
and dangerousness
a certain terribleness subtlety and
strength that does not permit contempt
to develop
according to slave morality those who
are evil thus inspire fear
according to master morality it is
precisely those who are good that
inspire and wish to inspire fear well
the batter felt to be contemptible let
me paraphrase this
slave morality is motivated by fear
in part fear of the power of master
morality
nietzsche tells a story about this
the slave morality in order to protect
itself against the powerful
tries to reverse the values nietzsche
calls it trans valuation of values it
inverts what nietzsche regards as the
natural order of values
in order to protect themselves against
the strong the slaves call power
bad or evil and they celebrate weakness
and servility and humility and so in
that inversion they attempt to give
themselves power over the strong
it wants
not to suffer
it's motivated above all by comfortable
self-preservation
and it wants to organize the world
around its fear of suffering this
is the key to nietzsche's analysis
because nietzsche tells us that
suffering
is the condition
for growth
the master morality
seeks
suffering
the slave morality seeks to avoid it
the desire to avoid suffering is a
natural one
it makes sense but what would it mean
to be without suffering
what is the most terrible thought
most human beings have
it's death
human beings are aware
of their death
dogs
and cats
also die
but they don't dwell on death
they don't think about it they don't get
depressed worrying about when they're
going to die nietzsche thinks that human
beings often suffer greatly in their
awareness of death and it's this
awareness of death that creates the
horizon in which human beings try to
live and think about meaning in their
lives
to escape ultimate suffering means to
not ever have to think about death and
to never think about death
would require that human beings
lack all self-knowledge that is it would
mean that they become animals again
nietzsche sees in modern culture
especially in democratic socialism a
whole
institutional
push
to prevent people from ever
suffering and nietzsche thinks that the
end result of this will be what he calls
the last man the last man is ultimately
no longer human he's simply an animal
concerned about basic biological needs
he's someone who no longer has to think
about anything high the master morality
then nietzsche thinks is the person who
resists that
will create some new values that will
give something for human beings to
strive for to keep them
human
at his core nietzsche is defending
humanity he's worried ultimately that
democratic socialism and the modern
project is going to base us will make us
no longer
human
we may not agree with nietzsche's
critique of christianity
or his account of morality
or of the idea that we only create our
own world
but
we might see something very true in
nietzsche's worry about the end result
of the modern project what nietzsche
calls the last man
we might see anita real warnings about
tendencies in our own culture
you